♪ I go out late at night
Just to see what I can find ♪
♪ Staying in the shadows
Where the light don't ever shine ♪
♪ Having one-way conversations
With the darkness in my mind ♪
♪ He does all the talking
Because I'm the quiet kind ♪
♪ So peel it off
And pull 'em down ♪
♪ Let me see it, turn around ♪
♪ Just lay back, let it happen,
And remember to breathe ♪
♪ Staying off the radar
Like a bomber on the run ♪
♪ Do another lap around
The target just for fun ♪
♪ Staying quiet, keeping calm
Until I find the one ♪
♪ Feel the wave wash over me
When the deed is done ♪
♪ So peel it off
And pull 'em down ♪
♪ Let me see it, turn around ♪
♪ Just lay back, let it happen
And remember to breathe ♪
♪ Just lay back ♪
♪ Just lay back, let it happen ♪
♪ And remember to breathe ♪